[ Laughter ]
-Hello. How do, Padraic?
-Sit somewhere else.
-Huh?
Uh, but I have me pint there,
Colm.
-He has his pint there, Colm,
from when he came in and ordered
his pint before.
-Well, okay, I'll sit
somewhere else.
-Are you rowing?
-I didn't think we were rowing.
-Well, you are rowing.
He's sitting outside on his own
like a whatchamacallit.
-It does look like we're rowing.
I suppose I best go
talk to him, so...
See what all this is
feckin' about.
-That would be the best thing.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
That was a clip from
"The Banshees of Inisherin."
We're here with two of the best,
Brendan Gleeson
and Colin Farrell.
A really lovely depiction --
even though, obviously
a great deal of conflict --
of how cozy,
how warm pub life can be.
You obviously shot inside
for a great deal of this film.
And you've seen -- obviously
there's a great deal
of drinking,
as we see in the clip.
But that's not
the real Guinness.
-Guinness Zero,
thank God for it.
-Okay.
Why thank God for Guinness Zero?
-Couple of reasons.
On the production, we would have
had to drink just an inutterable
amount of [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
And it's not [bleep].
It's actually really tasty,
the Guinness Zero.
It's a bit sweet for his tongue
because likes the proper stuff.
-Yeah.
-But they only come out with it,
and it's delicious.
And I've given it to a few other
people who are, you know,
stout aficionados who are like,
"Jesus, that's an eight."
[ Laughter ]
"That's an eight, you know?"
So I loved it.
And plus, when I got to go home
to Dublin the last time, I got
to have a few pints with me mate
Rue, I was telling Brendan,
and it was first time in about
16 years I got to sit in pub for
four hours and have eight pints.
-Yeah.
-Of zero alcohol.
The zero's the important part.
-Just to have the pint there
and just have the chat,
it was wonderful.
-And also, on film sets,
you always have to drink
the fake stuff.
What were they before Guinness?
-Everything was ghastly. It was
actual cream and a cup of --
-Grape juice with cream.
[ Audience oohs ]
All sorts of drink you shouldn't
be mixing, you know.
-Flat Coke and stuff like that
with a bunch of --
all sorts of unspeakables on top
of it.
So it was okay,
but if somebody --
you know, if you had
a lot of takes,
and you had to drink in it,
it was just -- I mean.
[ Speaking foreign language ]
They say.
"It's important
to suffer for art."
[ Laughter ]
And this was suffering.
-It did seem like -- you know,
this takes place in the '20s,
very close quarters.
The houses that you were in
seemed cramped.
But is that what -- I mean, did
you travel when you were young?
Did you go on vacation to places
like these islands?
-Yeah, well, I have been going
down there for a long time.
And I think you spent --
-I spent a little bit of time
on the island we shot on,
Inishmore, when I was a young --
when I was 17 or 18, we went
there for a week on the piss
but I can't remember any of it.
[ Laughter ]
-I couldn't remember Achill
because there was a lot of mist
and rain on the days
I was there.
So it was fantastic, actually,
just to go and see it in
all its magnificence.
-But I guess -- So, this is
your home in the film.
-On the most beautiful beach.
-Gorgeous.
-Extraordinary.
Keem Bay, wasn't it?
-Yeah, you're looking wrong way.
Out that way is --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That way looks out this way.
The whole Atlantic is there,
it's beautiful.
-That's just where Morris bit
me, actually.
-That's exactly where
Morris bit him.
-Is this very triggering?
Is this triggering every time?
-Ow, ow! It's phantom pain.
Phantom pain.
-We can't find any still from
the film you're not having just
about to be bit
or having just been bit.
-I need a tetanus now.
-There's a bit of, you know,
the fantastical and folklore
in the very title.
You know, banshees,
plays into the film.
Was that something -- when you
were growing up, was the sort of
the fantasy element a part of
your lives at all?
-In a kind of a way.
I was -- We were both city boys,
so it wasn't quite as prevalent
in there.
But there was a thing called
the boogeyman,
which I think you have a version
of over here.
-Yeah.
-And you kind of tell each other
ghost stories and kind of
frighten the life out of
everybody, and they would
always -- the older people would
tell it to you before you go to
bed, so you had to like --
So I always thought it was great
fun because it was --
you could get really scared but
you kind of, you know, you maybe
would take a sly look around
underneath the bed or wherever,
but it never really
frightened us.
But I had to babysit a young
German child
at one point that went out --
-Good line.
[ Laughter ]
-I had never babysat
anybody or anything before that,
and I went in, and I thought --
I think this kid
was about 4 or 5.
And I told him about the story
about the boogeyman
and he was traumatized,
essentially.
-Yeah, 'cause you're
a very convincing actor.
[ Laughter ]
-The parents came back and they
said, "What have you done?
What have you done
to our child?"
He was in there screaming.
So yeah, there was always
a little bit of crossover
between reality
and the fictional.
-Yeah.
-Even in those days.
-You mentioned you guys are both
from Dublin.
I went over with my family
in August.
-Did ya?
-For a college football game.
My university played over there.
-Your university played?
Because I know Navy and the Army
play there usually.
-Yeah, so we had -- it was
Northwestern-Nebraska
over there in that --
-Was it --
-The beautiful football stadium,
the new one.
-Aviva?
-Yeah, Aviva.
And it was great, but --
-Did people turn out?
-People turned out, yeah.
I wouldn't say it was full,
full, but it was alright.
Oh, a very -- a lovely thing
happened, which was they --
the registers weren't working.
There was no way to take money.
-Ah, shut up, now!
The registers work in Ireland!
[Bleep]!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come to Ireland where
the registers don't work.
[ Laughter ]
-He would've turned on the news
and the televisions
and see what was up,
but there was no television.
[ Laughter ]
[Bleep].
-It was great. The whole time
I felt like I was in the '20s.
[ Laughter ]
-What happened though?
-No, but they -- it was like,
you know, 15, 20 minutes of
everybody being really happy --
sorry, being unhappy because
nobody could get anything
to drink, and then they just
said basically "[Bleep] it,
everything is free."
[ Laughter ]
Which we thought was very --
a great example of
Irish hospitality.
-Oh, my God, that's amazing.
-What did you have to do
to bust up the registers?
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
-You know, these days you just
need to know one hacker.
That's all it is.
[ Laughter ]
But we spent the whole week
being very charmed
by the host city.
-Did you stay in Dublin or did
you head out west at all?
-My brother and parents went --
They were golfing the weekend.
I just went in for the game,
but we had a very charming
taxi driver who had the most
Dublin of lines, I think,
which is, we got into the car,
and my mom will ask
a lot of questions.
She's somebody who
she wants to know the day.
And we get in the car, and she
says, "Alright, I have a lot of
questions about
what we're doing today."
And the taxi driver -- mind you,
this is someone we've known
all of 15 seconds -- said,
"I'll tell you what we're going
to do today.
One, I'm going to drop you off
at the pub, and two,
you're going to stop asking
so many [bleep] questions."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Lovely!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, you know, I can't believe
we had to go all the way
to Ireland to get someone
to tell my mom the thing
we've been wanting to tell her.
[ Laughter ]
-That is because all taxi
drivers in Dublin
think of themselves
as talk show hosts.
Where they do the talking.
-Well, it's just such
a wonderful film.
I should also say, your
co-stars, Kerry and Barry --
-Oh, gosh.
-They're wonderful.
-Isn't Kerry extraordinary
in the film?
-She's extraordinary.
I'm very excited.
She's coming on here as well,
and I can't wait to tell her
in person.
-Ah, you'll love her.
She's brilliant.
-Kerry brought tears to eyes
that you would not imagine
you can bring tears to.
-Yeah.
-That performance is
extraordinary, it really is.
-She's gut-wrenching in it.
Yeah, she's gut-wrenching.
-And funny and brilliant.
-Yeah.
-Such a vivacity about her.
So it was a bit like that.
Like Martin had worked with
all that cast,
apart from Barry Keoghan,
who is also kind of
pretty amazing in it.
And he knew the people
he was dealing with.
So part of the writing was
allowing them
to bring what they bring.
And you can kind of tell.
I don't think there's
a false note in it.
-There really isn't.
And I say this about no films --
when it was over, I thought,
"I could have spent another hour
with everybody there."
So it's really great.
And it's just always such a joy
to have you both here with us.
Thank you so much.
-Thanks, Seth.
-"The Banshees of Inisherin"
will be in theaters everywhere
October 21st.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."